Let's now take a look at layering.
By and large, security is enhanced because it is straightforward to
add a security layer between the system and its environment.
As far as the effect of the other four qualities on layering, performance may
be reduced because the response to external events must be passed up and
down the layers, which may in, may also increase context swapping.
Maintainability, on the other hand,
might be improved because of the stable interlayer protocols and
interfaces would lead to well-defined and reusable components.
It may even be possible to replace an entire layer or insert other layers.
Reliability may be reduced because an event may be handled in multiple layers.
That is, making it hard to find,
when something goes wrong, what the responsible layer is.
However the higher layers may have an oversight capability to provide
the necessary redundancy to improve reliability.
As far as safety is concerned, similar to security,
it maybe easy to insert safety monitoring layers.